chaque année à peu près 300 000
visiteurs visitent le château de Blois
il ne voit pas cette pièce nous sommes
au second étage du château des coulisses
qui montrent des travaux de rénovation
le château royal de Blois est un château
municipal c'est la municipalité qui est
donc chargée des investissements et de
la préservation de ce patrimoine nous
allons voir avec l'adjointe à la ville
de Blois en charge du patrimoine Jérôme
bougeot comment se fait ce choix et
cette politique de patrimonial dans un
espace aussi gigantesque quelles sont
les choix et les possibilités d'une
municipalité quand il faut préserver un
patrimoine comme celui-là qui donc on va
commencer évidemment par ce qui nous
couvre la toiture en premier lieu
puisqu'il y a toujours quelques fissures
ici ou là ou quelques petites poches
d'eau qui peuvent s'incruster donc on va
commencer par sécuriser le bâti
ensuite la charpente bien sûr on
pourrait avoir quelques dégradations la
charpente est très ancienne on doit les
sécuriser et puis ensuite il y a tout le
reste puisque ce qui tient la toiture et
charpente ce sont les maçonneries et
donc là aussi on doit s'attaquer au
maçonnerie comme ici par exemple alors
ici on est où et il se fait quoi on est
au deuxième étage du château
au dessus des anciens appartements de
Catherine de Médicis et on a ici un mur
renaissance pour lequel il y a des
dégradations on s'est rendu compte
visuellement qu'il y a des fissures qui
sont à la fois
longitudinales ou en profondeur donc on
a un certain nombre de fissuresomètres
qui sont installés et qui nous
permettent de constater presque au jour
le jour si oui ou non on a des
dégradations je vous propose vous en
avez parlé un petit peu de découvrir les
charpente c'est vrai que ici au château
de Blois toutes les époques ont produit
une charpente ça va du Moyen-Âge à nos
jours je vous propose de découvrir la
valeur patrimoniale de ces étés en bois
qui sont sous les combles
le château royal de Blois à la
particularité de présenter aux visiteurs
plusieurs époques de construction du
Moyen-Âge au 17e siècle un
enchevêtrement d'architecture médiéval
gothique ou Renaissance particulièrement
visible dans les charpente
[Musique]
de la même époque que la cathédrale
Notre-Dame de Paris l'ossature bois dite
en forme de coque de bateau renversé au
dessus de la salle des étages généraux
est un joyau des savoir-faire du 13e
siècle la charpente qu'on a là est une
charpente qui a été datée de 1214 par
une analyse scientifique qu'on appelle
la dendrochronologie c'est à dire
l'analyse des cernes du bois et c'est
donc une charpente médiévale et
aujourd'hui la seule connue de charpente
civils j'entends bien d'un édifice civil
pour cette période là puisque c'est la
charpente de la salle de justice des
contes de Blois
une balade dans les combles du château
raconte l'histoire de nos ancêtres
bâtisseurs ce type de bâtiment ce qui
était intéressant c'est ce qu'on voyait
d'extérieur les beaux décors les
sculptures et puis derrière et bien vous
avez des parties qui sont effectivement
non décorées beaucoup plus ordinaires
mais
on a un espèce de sentiment quand aussi
promène sur un peu de découverte
d'aventures pour les familiers des lieux
chaque partie du château a un prénom
donc là on est chez Gaston on va voir la
charpente
Gaston d'Orléans le frère de Louis XII
c'est lui qui commande un architecte
François Mansart c'est elle du château
c'est charpente et belle en fait elle
est magnifique on a une sorte une vraie
œuvre d'art parce que le jeu des
chevrons des poutres des signes un
espace et des lignes et une forme aussi
ça a une forme très très particulière
alors que les charpentiers appellent à
entrer retroussé enfin bon passons sur
la terminologie complexe mais ça vous
donne effectivement une sorte d'oeuvre
d'art qui voilà ajoutez un volume
c'est bon
tout simplement
comme vous l'avez vu pour les charpente
il y a effectivement les murs la toiture
qui sont toujours à préserver dans un
immense monument comme le château de
Blois un château municipal alors est-ce
que ça vous coûte cher de sauvegarder ce
patrimoine de le garder en état si on
devait intégralement reprendre tous les
travaux pour éviter ces étés si on
devait reprendre aussi des travaux plus
simples de simples nettoyage autour des
fenêtres de rejoindre toi man des
pierres bien sûr tout ça ça coûterait
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'euros
ce qui est l'équivalent de de tous les
travaux qui sont réalisés sur une année
dans tout le patrimoine de la ville de
Blois que ce soit du patrimoine routier
ou du patrimoine immobilier peu importe
donc évidemment tout injecter en une
fois sur sur ce bâtiment c'est
impossible dans les attractivités
propres aux monuments le château royal
de Blois demain nous découvrirons ce qui
fait venir aussi des visiteurs le soir
il s'agit du son et lumière